eigentlich gibt es jede Menge zu tun
melde mich zum Dienst doch offenbar wird
kaum noch jemand arbeiten
sagen sie ganz Deutschland sucht
Fachkräfte wie sieht es bei Ihnen aus es
gibt so und so viel Arbeitslose und wir
haben keine Leute die arbeiten mal also
ich verstehe das nicht man musste sich
um eine Ausbildung Platz kämpfen quasi
heute wird es hinterher geschmissen
überall fehlen Leute wo sind die alle
hin
[Musik]
die kündigen alle weil ihnen die work
live-balance plötzlich furchtbar wichtig
ist
gleichzeitig gehen Millionen in Rente
steuert Deutschland ins Desaster
[Musik]
es wird aus Unternehmer sich zu
engständig gesucht Ich habe mir das Ziel
gesetzt dass ich anders sein will als
andere und das hat funktioniert
ich bin Sarah Tacke ZDF Journalistin und
gehe dorthin wo die personalnud am
größten ist
ich will wissen was können wir gegen den
Arbeitskräftemangel tun
[Musik]
ich bin im Gefängnis in Rohrbach bei
Mainz Sicherheitstraining für zukünftige
Justizvollzugsbeamte sie proben hier
heute den Ernstfall
die Übergriffe sind mehr geworden in der
letzten fünf bis sechs Jahre das kann
man beobachten die Tendenz steigt die
die Übergriffe werden immer häufiger
wenn Häftlinge aggressiv werden müssen
Beamte mit voller Montur in die Zellen
diese gesamte Situation ist einfach
extrem vorne also körperlich aber
natürlich auch also quasi so ein Angriff
abwehren
[Musik]
mehr Aggressionen in der JVA das liegt
auch am Personalmangel ein Problem für
die Beamten wie den stellvertretenden
vollzugschefi
[Musik]
wir würden uns jetzt gerade hier kurz
einen Personen Notrufgerät für sie holen
und dann gehen wir gleich weiter und das
ist wenn also wenn ich Hilfe brauche
genau das Ding hat Alarmfunktion
und das dafür starten
181 Justizvollzugsbeamte bewachen hier
500 Männer und Frauen viele Gefängnisse
sind am Limit es fehlen Leute um mit dem
Gefangenen zu arbeiten damit diese nach
der Haft nicht erneut straffällig werden
das Ziel vom Vollzug ist es jetzt nicht
den Gefangenen zu bekommen wegzusperren
23 Stunden nur eine Stunde rauszulassen
und sonst nichts zu machen da ist wieder
dem Inhaftierten mitgeholfen noch uns
mitgeholfen wir möchten dass er ein
geregelten Arbeitsalltag bekommt oder
generellen geregelten aber im Alltag
bekommt
in der Zelle hocken statt wie
Sozialisierung das ist die Realität in
vielen deutschen Gefängnissen 17 Stellen
sind hier derzeit umgesetzt
auf 11 Uhr hätten wir einen Ausfall bei
der transportstation da müssen wir
gucken dass man bedient sind also mal
gucken ob man im Bereich vielleicht zu
machen müssen
mehr durchführen ich würde sagen
vielleicht die Arbeitstherapie machen
die ist okay
das so wenig Kollegen da sind dass sie
dann Bereiche schließen müssen
wird der Gefangene nur weggesperrt haben
alle ein Problem die Häftlinge die
Vollzugsbeamten und am Ende auch wir
draußen denn wer im Gefängnis kein
geregelten Alltag lernen wird in
Freiheit mit höherer Wahrscheinlichkeit
wieder kriminell
wenn ich jetzt hier jemand an der
regelmäßige Arbeit führen will
dass er eben morgens kommt sein Tag hier
verbringt mit mit Tätigkeiten und er
soll was erlernen und ich sag nur zwei
Stunden hier Männer umziehen zurück auf
den Haftraum wir müssen zu machen ich
muss woanders hin ist natürlich ganz
ganz schlecht ja dann kommt natürlich
früher oder später auch der Frust dann
bei den gefangen sind warum stehe ich
morgens überhaupt auf bleibe ich doch
gleich liegen das interessiert letztlich
draußen niemand solange es hier ruhig
ist und nichts passiert und kein
ausdrucksversuch ist oder oder irgendein
was
schlagzeilenrechtliches passiert
interessiert niemand
sie kümmern sich oft nur um das Nötigste
die Sicherheit mindestens alle zwei
Monate wird jede Zelle durchsucht
die schmutzige gefangen das ist halt
jetzt wirklich ganz cool ja müssen wir
aber leider dran weil das ist halt auch
eine gute Versteckmöglichkeit
ich helfe hier heute mit und spreche
auch mit Insassen über die Situation
hallo
[Musik]
ich habe hier einmal Hähnchen mit
Klößchen bitteschön was macht das so mit
ihrer Stimmung wenn wenn einfach wenn so
eine Woche ist wo man so gut wie gar
nicht normal ist schon deprimiert dann
eventuell keiner da wo die Post uns
geben kann oder ist keiner da wo uns
telefonieren das ist halt
sind so Kleinigkeiten ja aber das ist
für uns aber sehr viel
mir wird klar dass Personalproblem
betrifft uns alle auch in vielen anderen
Branchen vielen Leute
[Musik]
2012 gab es knapp eine Millionen offene
Stellen heute vielen schon fast 2
Millionen Arbeitskräfte
[Musik]
das Gastgewerbe ist besonders stark vom
Personalmangel betroffen ich will mir
ein eigenes Bild machen bin in Thüringen
beim Burghof Kyffhäuser 35 Mitarbeiter
heute darf ich mit anpacken am Abend
findet der große Abschlussball eines
Tanzkurses statt
[Musik]
auf uns kommen heute 150 Essen
innerhalb von einer Stunde anderthalb
unter Anleitung von Küchenchef Tobias
huske hätte ich mit eine Soljanka zu
kochen
oh
Freunde das ist richtig gut
nur drei gelernte Köche arbeiten derzeit
auf dem Burghof eigentlich viel zu wenig
für die vielen Gäste
Inhaberin ist Katrin Auerbach die
ständige Suche nach Personal treibt
ihren Puls nach oben
schwierig wenn wenn Feiertage sind und
wenn das dann eben Montag sind schiebt
sich die ganze Woche und dann wird schon
elendig schwer das so hinzukriegen dass
auch noch jeder seine zwei drei Tage
bekommt ja und dann
denke ich schon darüber nach mir so
einen kleinen hilfsroboter zu kaufen ne
ich habe mir schon Angebot machen lassen
von so einem kleinen süßen Schnuckelchen
der dann da so auf vier Rollen durchs
Restaurant kehrt und die Attraktion ist
ja weiß ich noch nicht müssen überlegen
16.000 Euro das ist auch ein krass
vorerst müssen noch wir Menschen ran in
zwei Stunden kommen die Gäste
als Mark Frank hier Restaurantleiter
wurde hatte er noch achtfachkräfte im
Service
jetzt sind es nur noch drei
stellst du eine Veränderung fest in den
20 Jahren
ich möchte keiner mehr diesen Job machen
an dem Wochenende möchte jemand arbeiten
und Nachtschicht viele Restaurants
müsste ja sogar schließen oder öffnen
nur wenige Tage
kein Personal haben wo sind die alle hin
das müssten wir auch gern
von den Gastrobetrieben die 2021 Stellen
ausgeschrieben hatten konnten nur 35%
diese Stellen auch zeitnah besetzen bei
allen anderen Betrieben blieben Stellen
offen
es geht los die Gäste kommen letzte
Einweisung im Serviceteam
und wir haben also uns gehört jetzt die
Seite
[Musik]
in der Küche wird es jetzt stressig 150
essen müssen raus der wird jede helfende
Hand gebraucht
ich sehe du hast viele die sind top
ausgebildeten hast du ausgebildet aber
auch Rentner oder das sind so meine
Joker die mir in der Sommersaison helfen
der Henry z.B der ist Minijobber ja und
und sein Bruder der steht hier an
solchen Tagen und wäscht ab ja das auch
gab was bist du eigentlich na ja das
sieht aus wie ein Rentner oder
ja doch ja also Minijobber Rentner ja ja
also das ist ja
wer hat Schnitzel Lachsfilet schönen
guten Abend wer möchte einen leckeren
Burger wir machen hier 150 Essen in zwei
Stunden und ich kann nur sagen es ist
extrem krass also auch körperlich ja
Teller sind heiß müssen Tempo machen
damit wir hier durchkommen aber es ist
auch eine schöne Herausforderung muss
ich sagen
wir haben noch gar nicht bestellen
dürfen ach so ja wann sie mal noch ich
sag bescheid dass sie noch auf dem
Trockenen sitzen und auch Hunger haben
also die waren bisschen traurig die
einen haben schon was zu essen und zu
trinken und sie haben noch nicht mal was
zu trinken bist du dran
die Gäste wünschen sich einen
entspannten Abend die anderen müssen
schuften
wir haben jetzt dieses Jahr wirklich das
erste Mal aus der Erfahrung der letzten
beiden Jahre eine Woche nach den
Sommerferien eine Betriebsschließung im
Sommer das ist noch nie passiert aber es
ist absolut notwendig weil dann alle auf
auf so dünnem Eislaufen und die Haut so
dünn ist das immer danach das läuft
super wie ein Länderspiel bis dahin und
dann kracht das untereinander weil
keiner mehr die Kraft hat ja und wir
machen das jetzt einfach mal damit alle
die ein Stück runterkommen und wir den
nächsten Schritt bis zum Jahresende
schaffen wie würde Deutschland aussehen
wenn Gaststätten wie eure zu machen
würden
ja du hast das ja in vielen Orten schon
also es wird viel Geld ausgegeben um
unglaublich schöne Wanderwege zu
installieren ja zu installieren aber die
Leute kommen doch nicht wenn sie
nirgends schlafen können wenn sie
nirgends essen können also wofür haben
wir das alles wenn am Ende niemand da
ist der so eine Häuser bespielt und die
Gäste sind ja da das ist ja das
verrückte eine paradoxe Situation ja
also die Gäste sind da und es ist keiner
mehr bereit zu arbeiten in der Zeit wo
die Gäste sind
wo sind die Leute alle hin die in
Branchen wie der Gastronomie so dringend
gebraucht werden
[Musik]
im Laufe der Pandemie und der lockdowns
sind 10.000 Mitarbeiter in die
Logistikbranche oder den Einzelhandel
gewechselt
sowie er René Biebricher
in der Gastro ist es einfach bis heute
und das weiß ich von Kollegen die immer
noch da sind zu häufig spontan oh das
dauert jetzt doch länger kannst du mal
vier Stunden dranhängen oder eben du
hattest eigentlich morgen frei da ist
aber einer weggefallen kannst Du nicht
doch reinkommen
heute arbeitet der 40-Jährige in einem
weinversandhandel
Bestellungen entgegennehmen
Kundenwünsche bearbeiten wie die
Gastronomie häufig mit ihren Leuten
umgeht macht ihn wütend
20 Jahre hat er die kellnert zuletzt als
Barchef in einem Hotel
mittlerweile habe ich drei
Bandscheibenvorfälle gesammelt ich habe
eine sehr sehr lange Beziehung gehabt
die dann mit immer länger werdender
Karriere doch auch ein bisschen darunter
gelitten hat dass meine Arbeitszeiten
nicht wirklich beziehungsfreundlich sind
sowas wie Familienplanung ist leider
auch daran letztendlich gescheitert
[Musik]
während der Pandemie wurde ihm gekündigt
er musste sich wie viele andere umsehen
und wurde ein bisschen zu seinem Glück
gezwungen
gefühlt in wirklich wurde mein Gehalt
verdoppelt also ich bekomme plötzlich
Geld dafür dass ich gefühlt weniger
mache
seit über zwei Jahren hier und freue
mich immer noch wie ein Schneekönig
[Musik]
gut 2000 Euro netto verdient er jetzt
mehr Lohn bessere Arbeitsbedingungen das
sind die Stellschrauben
über so lange Zeit hat die Gastro
konsequent und erfolgreich daran
gearbeitet ein schlechtes Bild von sich
selber zu erzeugen ich schließe für mich
momentan aus wieder in als
Restaurantfachmann zu arbeiten
und und unterstelle einfach
dass ich keinen Job finden würde der
mich glücklich macht das in Themas eine
Bezahlung ich gehe mal eine feste von
der Gastronomie jetzt vielleicht das
noch überdenken muss und das ist
natürlich auch mal ein Faktor deswegen
meine Arbeitskräfte bekommt oder nicht
bekommt das Problem aktuell sinken die
Löhne in Deutschland aber niemand haben
inflationsbereinigt zum dritten Mal in
Folge weniger verdient
2022 - 4% im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
[Musik]
wer Mitarbeiter bekommen und halten will
wird mehr zahlen müssen das klingt
simpel wirkt aber auch Gefahren denn
manch ein Betrieb dürfte sich höhere
Löhne schlicht gar nicht leisten können
[Musik]
ich bin in München auf einer großen
handwerksmesse auch diese Branche leidet
massiv unter der Personalnot die
Handwerksberufe haben heute ein Drittel
weniger Azubis als noch vor 20 Jahren
und wenn wir die demografische Kurve
anschauen sind wir erst am Anfang das
heißt das Thema der Fachkräfte
Problematik wird sich in den nächsten
Jahren noch drastisch zu spitzen
wer wird also in 10 20 Jahren im
Handwerk arbeiten die Branche braucht
Nachwuchs und zwar dringend
um der Messe etwas Glanz zu verleihen
werden zwei prominente erwartet die gern
Klartext sprechen ich treffe Markus Lanz
und Richard David Precht vor ihrem
Auftritt im Backstage-Bereich sie
kritisieren ein System in dem sich
arbeiten oft gar nicht mehr lohne ein
großes Problem liegt einfach daran dass
jemand der bei uns Bürgergeld bezieht
nicht bis zur steuerbewässerungsgrenze
was dazu verdienen darf wenn es also
möglich ist ich bekomme Bürgergeld aber
ich kann bis ungefähr 15.000 im Jahr
dazu verdienen steuerfrei dazu verdienen
dann habe ich aber extrem viele Leute
die das nutzen würden und die dann in
der Gastronomie arbeiten würden und in
vielen Bereichen wo man jetzt nicht
hochqualifiziert arbeiten muss geht aus
der Logik nicht also die Logik des
Systems du kriegst Hartz IV weil du
nicht arbeitest und nicht du kriegst hat
vier und kannst ja noch 15.000 im Jahr
dazu verdienen das passt sozusagen von
der DNA nicht zusammen ich hatte mal
eine Debatte mit Stefan weil dazu denn
niedersächsischen Ministerpräsidenten
der der sagte ja so können Sie auch
nicht sagen dass jemand der drei Kinder
hat 800 Euro weniger verdient oder 900
Euro als jemand der Bürgergeld bezieht
sagte doch meinte nein da kann man doch
aufstocken und dann kann man Wohngeld
beantragen und so weiter und ich dachte
was ist das für Menschenbild was ist
denn das für eine für eine
Lebenswirklichkeit wenn man Leuten die
Arbeiten gehen und stolz sind auf das
was sie tun und damit auch von dem was
sie tun leben möchten wenn man den
erklärt und übrigens gehst du jetzt noch
bitte zum Amt und sagt bitte bitte bitte
bitte jetzt hätte ich noch gerne
Wohngeld hier und dann noch
Kinderzuschuss oder das ist ein Mensch
im Bild von dem ich glaube das ist kein
gutes
lands und Precht werden wir bei ihrem
Auftritt gleich wieder treffen
[Musik]
klar ist Arbeiten im Niedriglohnbereich
war immer schon unattraktiv und heute
sicher mehr denn je doch wie kann es
sein dass sogar im Handwerk wo
mittlerweile gutes Geld zu verdienen ist
so viele Leute fehlen
mir
Schleswig-Holstein
[Musik]
ich besuche die Malermeisterin Jessica
Hansen
sie will den Personalmangel nicht länger
tatenlos zusehen
guten Morgen
sie hat ihren Betrieb vor einem Jahr
komplett umgestellt
da hatte ich halt super viele Aufträge
und wenig Leute und hatte halt auch
Probleme mit der Personalgewinnung und
musste mir was einfallen lassen dann
habe ich über Social Media halt gepostet
flexible Arbeitszeiten 4 Tage Woche und
hatte innerhalb von drei Wochen 50
Bewerbungen nicht ihr Ernst 50
also das tat mir schon so ein bisschen
leid weil ich kann sie ja nicht allein
stellen das geht ja nicht danke schön
[Musik]
guten Morgen guten Morgen
ihre Gesellen dürfen selbst entscheiden
ob sie um 7 Uhr oder 8 Uhr beginnen
heute bei Annika
[Gelächter]
also ehrlich so diese Grundstimmung ist
extrem positiv und auch so dieses wir
sind wir sind eine Truppe und von dem
was ich gehört habe wie man hier
arbeiten kann vier Tage worauf flexible
würde ich auch mitmachen würde ich auch
mitmachen ja
vier Tage Woche Bezahlung über Tarif
rund 2800 € brutto so hat Jessica Hansen
jetzt mehr als 20 Mitarbeiter
[Musik]
früher mussten ihre Kunden bis zu 6
Monate auf einen Termin warten heute
sind die Preise höher dafür geht's
schneller
hattest du Vorbild jemand der auch
umgestellt hat bei dem du gesagt hast
ach mensch naja Dänemark macht es ja
schon seit Jahrzehnten vor also die
waren immer so ein bisschen Vorreiter
für mich ne da war ja auch also ganz
viele sind natürlich auch viele Maler
nach Dänemark gegangen weil die vier
Tage Woche natürlich attraktiv war da
haben sie dreieinhalb Tage gearbeitet
oder vier und dann sind sie nach Hause
gefahren ne also ich habe ganz oft
gedacht so ja das ist toll
Jessica bringt mich zu der Baustelle auf
der ich heute mitarbeiten darf
bereit
Christian Tabel ihr Angestellter zeigt
mir wie man eine wandspachtelt
[Musik]
wieso hast du gesagt ich will bei Frau
Hansen arbeiten ja da ist es im Prinzip
das Konzept es ist sehr sehr flexibel
gehalten ich muss zum Beispiel morgens
meinen kleinen Sohn in die Kita fahren
so in der Regel ist in Malerfirmen 7 Uhr
Arbeitsbeginn und das ist und bleibt
auch so sicher der schon Diskussionen
wir können das nicht ändern weil dann
würde das ja jeder machen wollen und und
und das stand hier gar nicht so Debatte
[Musik]
flexible Arbeitsmodelle sind selten in
der Branche ganz sicher einer der Gründe
warum heute gut 50.000 Menschen weniger
eine Ausbildung im Handwerk beginnen als
noch vor 20 Jahren
[Musik]
dein Blick jetzt auch nicht nur auf
deinen Betrieb sondern insgesamt
das glaubst du wie viel Zukunft Handwerk
handwerksbetriebe haben
ja es ist so eine gemischten Gefühle ne
also wir als Handwerksbetriebe müssen
jetzt Gast geben und zeigen dass wir die
kommt zu uns genau kommt zu uns wichtig
ist dass wir die Jugendlichen abholen
und aber auch ganz viel die Eltern dass
wir überzeugen können Mensch schickt ein
Kind ins Handwerk dann wird aus dem auch
was
Nürnberg Bundesagentur für Arbeit
anders als ihre Vorgänger suchtchefin
Andrea Nahles nicht Jobs für Arbeitslose
sondern gewissermaßen umgekehrt
Arbeitslose für jede Menge Jobs also zur
Zeit ist es definitiv so dass egal wo
ich hinkomme die Leute mich nach
Fachkräfte weil fragen ob das die
Arbeitnehmer oder die Arbeitgeberseite
ist spielt gar keine Rolle Fachkräfte
wird das Thema der nächsten 10 Jahre alt
und das Gute ist dass man was tun kann
das ist jetzt kein Schicksal die Behörde
steht unter Druck denn der
Fachkräftemangel kostet die deutsche
Wirtschaft 100 Milliarden Euro und zwar
jedes Jahr
also wenn Sie mich fragen wo können wir
neue Arbeitskräfte auch finden gucke ich
zunächst mal ins Inland bei den Frauen
da haben wir halt Teilzeit ja vielleicht
gehen aber auch fünf Stunden oder zehn
Stunden mehr wenn man eine halbe Stunde
morgens später oder nachmittags früher
weg kann und das Kind aus der Kita
abzuholen auch da sehe ich einfach
Potenzial das durch Verhandlungen auch
noch möglicherweise aufgeschossen werden
kann
tatsächlich stehen Frauen mit Kindern
unter sechs Jahren dem Arbeitsmarkt
häufig gar nicht zur Verfügung
und das obwohl
840.000 von Ihnen gerne mindestens in
Teilzeit arbeiten würden
[Musik]
sie ist eine von ihnen Julia Balzer ist
gelernte Erzieherin muss aber noch ihr
Anerkennungsjahr machen um ihre
Ausbildung abzuschließen was Ihr dafür
fehlt ein Kita Platz für ihr eigenes
Kind
wir haben schon in der Schwangerschaft
die kleine angemeldet im Januar 22 und
wir haben bis jetzt noch keine
Rückmeldung bekommen ob wir einen Platz
bekommen oder nicht ich habe jetzt nur
mit meinen alten Kolleginnen mal
gesprochen die mir dann aber auch gesagt
haben dass es ziemlich schlecht aussieht
mit einem Platz weil die warten
Wartelisten gerade in der Krippe sind
zwei seitig egal wo
und wir müssen da wahrscheinlich noch
einfach noch näher gedulden oder zwei
und gerade jetzt Erzieher die so trinkt
benötigt werden die werden dann halt
irgendwie vertröstet und ja zwei Jahren
Platz
fast 100.000 Kita Kräfte fehlen
deutschlandweit
besonders bizar Julia Balzer gilt
offiziell noch nicht einmal als
arbeitslos und gerät dadurch auch
finanziell in Nöte ich bekomme ja auch
kein Arbeitslosengeld das steht mir
einfach nicht zu weil ich ja keinen
Betreuungsplatz für die kleine habe
dementsprechend stehe ich im
Arbeitsmarkt nicht zur Verfügung und
kann es mir nicht beantragen aber ich
glaube irgendwann mal ich glaube das
verstehe deine Mutter will man auch
endlich mal wieder raus und erwachsene
Leute erwachsenengespräche führen und
nicht nur den ganzen Tag blablabla und
da da
wir haben ein riesiges Fachkräfteproblem
und bekommen die die arbeiten wollen
nicht in Arbeit absurd finde ich
auf der Handwerksmesse in München haben
jetzt auch die beiden prominenten Gäste
ihren großen Auftritt
[Musik]
muss Landes und Richard David Precht
vielen Dank Dankeschön
Glanz und Brecht erregen sich heute
nicht über die die nicht arbeiten können
sondern über die die nicht arbeiten
wollen wir sind so eine wahnsinnig
Gefühle der Gesellschaft geworden ja so
eine so eine hafermilchgesellschaft
sondern so eine wichsaft Truppe die die
die wirklich die ganze Zeit auf der
Suche nach der idealen Work-Life-Balance
ist also ich würde sogar noch etwas
radikaler sein ich würde sagen in der
Generation meine Eltern erst mal der
Großeltern haben sich 90% aller Menschen
wenn sie gearbeitet haben die Sinnfrage
gar nicht erst gestellt jetzt sieht es
natürlich so aus dass nahezu alle jungen
Menschen ins Leben gehen unter der
Vorstellung das Leben ist ein
Wunschkonzert was ist die Folge ja du
fängst was an und beim ersten leisen
gegenwindex das war das falsche schmeiß
die Flinte wieder ins Korn
was stimmt ist der Arbeitsmarkt hat sich
gewandelt viele würden gern weniger
arbeiten und dafür auch aufgehalt
verzichten allerdings gibt es
gleichzeitig Millionen Menschen die mehr
oder überhaupt arbeiten wollen den aber
der Zugang zum Arbeitsmarkt fehlt
[Musik]
Berlin hier kümmert sich Sozialarbeiter
Frank Schülke um junge Menschen die es
nicht schaffen eine Ausbildung zu
beginnen
[Musik]
nach seinem erweiterten
Hauptschulabschluss und vielen Jahren
ohne Plan hat schakologie nun eine
Perspektive der 21-Jährige taugt in
einem Förderprogramm der Deutschen Bahn
mit dem Ziel dort eine Ausbildung zu
beginnen
gerade hat er sein Zwischenzeugnis
bekommen
habe er hat gesehen ich bin motiviert
ich will
dementsprechend habe ich auch in der
Motivation
Respekt und das sind so kurzer Zeit weil
Schule war nicht so geil lief gar nicht
gut und jetzt
kommst du so eine Bewertung
und zu Hause läuft gut alles auch
also wirklich viel Freizeit habe ich
jetzt nicht weil ich komme nach der
Schule oder nach der Arbeit nach Hause
bin kaputt von Frühdienst und dann muss
ich auch noch auf mein Vater aufpassen
weil er ja ein Pflegefall geworden ist
Schlaganfall ja und dann ist die Zeit
auch von oben es ist arm was du noch zu
Hause machst ist für mich eine riesen
Herausforderung ich bin immer erstaunt
wie du es hinkriegst finde ich auch aber
Weiterkommen du willst Weiterkommen vor
allem auf jeden Fall
ich darf zu einem Beratungstermin der
beiden dazu kommen
Jugendliche mit Zuwanderungsgeschichte
haben es auf dem Arbeitsmarkt schwer sie
bleiben
öfter ohne Schulabschluss fangen selten
eine Ausbildung an und brechen sie
häufiger ab erst auf Nachfrage erzählt
mir schakul von seinen Erfahrungen in
der Schule
[Musik]
am Anfang hatte ich das immer recht
schwer
der Klasse anzupassen
dann haben die aber bemerkt ich bin der
deutschen Sprache mächtig und
haben keine Probleme in mir gesehen und
ich bin auch ein ganz lieber kerlord
Mensch vielleicht nicht so aussehe und
haben mich dann meist immer akzeptiert
was heißt das für mich aussieht wegen
die Paket naja vielleicht aufgrund
meiner Hautfarbe und mein Aussehen dass
ich so aussehe als würde ich gleich
Stress anfangen oder ähnliches weil ich
als Sozialarbeiter drauf gucke sehe ich
ganz klar Diskriminierung Ausgrenzung
und das führt dann dazu das ist nicht
nur hier in unserem Fall ein Thema
sondern auch bei vielen anderen
Jugendlichen dass das Selbstbewusstsein
unglaublich darunter leidet das
Selbstwertgefühl und das kommt zu diesem
ganzen anstrengenden Prozess ein
Ausbildung zur Staaten und sich mit den
Inhalten zu beschäftigen ist das etwas
was immer noch ein Top kommt und diese
ablehnungserfahrung führen dann dazu
dass junge Menschen sich vielleicht
zurückziehen und gar nicht mehr in
diesem Prozessen
angenehmen es wird ja immer gesagt wir
haben uns da auch mit einer Generation
zu tun die eben nicht mehr pünktlich und
fleißig und hart arbeitend ist sondern
die lieber erst um 12 aufstehen und und
von Instagram träumen und vom leichten
schnellen Geld
erlebst du das auch also ich kann diese
Wahrnehmung und auch diese
Pauschalisierung jungen Menschen
gegenüber absolut nicht bestätigen in
der Praxis sieht das völlig anders aus
sie suchen einen Weg und wollen ihr
Leben gestalten und das ist unglaublich
schwierig im Augenblick und da brauchen
sie Unterstützung aber Jugendliche die
per se nur in Anführungsstrichen ein
schönes Leben haben wollen sich nicht
bewegen wollen Geld vom Staat haben
wollen und immer erst 14 Uhr aufstehen
wollen finde ich in der Realität in
meiner Praxis nicht definitiv nicht
aber woran liegt es dann dass immer mehr
Jugendliche wieder arbeiten noch in
Schule Ausbildung oder Studium stecken
waren es vor der Pandemie noch 492.000
sind es nun schon 630.000 knapp ein
Drittel mehr wenn Leute sehen was für
die Jugendlichen alles gemacht wird da
wird so viel unternommen so viel Geld
ausgegeben um die Jugendlichen zu
aktivieren aber sonst einfach mal einen
Ausbildungsplatz anfangen einfach mal
morgens aufstehen und pünktlich da sein
ja also es gibt es für mich schon zwei
Ansatzpunkte also erstmal wird gar nicht
so viel Geld ausgegeben wie wenig Geld
für Soziale Arbeit oder zum Beispiel für
das Projekt Job in Mitte ausgegeben eine
Person für ein großraumbezogen das ist
total wenig also dieses Argument
verstehe ich gar nicht und das andere
ist die Passgenauigkeit muss er
hergestellt werden hier gibt's einen
jungen Menschen und der Kompetenzen und
Fähigkeiten und wir müssen gucken was zu
dem passt
ganz klar wir müssen für diese
Jugendlichen mehr tun denn das wird sich
am Ende für beide Seiten auszahlen
auch Andrea Nahles nimmt insbesondere
Menschen mit niedrigem oder ohne
Bildungsabschluss in den Blick denn sie
sind öfter als andere Gruppen lange Zeit
arbeitslos
das sind Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund und Menschen die
keinen Berufsabschluss haben da gibt es
auch noch eine Schnittmenge also da sehe
ich auch noch Potenzial dass wir durch
Qualifizierung durch schrittweise
Anheben der Qualifikationsniveaus jetzt
doch auch noch im Bereich der
Arbeitslosen noch Potenzial generieren
können
dabei sieht Nahles aber nicht nur ihre
Arbeitsagentur in der Pflicht sondern
auch die Unternehmen selbst
wenn wir sie Fragen versucht es doch mal
mit dem Kandidaten der vielleicht ein
paar Hemmnisse mitbringt oder der
vielleicht nicht ideale Voraussetzungen
mitbringt wir helfen euch dann auch
dabei dass der dann auch pünktlich da
ist oder das bestimmte Sachen dann auch
begleitet werden da haben wir immer noch
eine relativ große Zurückhaltung bei den
Arbeitgebern
in München stellt sich ein Unternehmer
den veränderten Bedingungen
[Musik]
Florian Kuhn er führt einen der größten
elektrobetriebe der Stadt
350 Mitarbeiter viel zu wenig für seine
Auftragslage er könnte noch 100 mehr
einstellen der Personalmangel ist schon
seit Jahren ein großes Thema für ihn die
Lösung sieht er vor allem bei sich
selbst
es wird aus Unternehmersicht zu
engständig gesucht also wir kommen aus
einer Welt wo KI Software Bewerbungen
ausgefiltert hat da haben wir uns auch
noch als Arbeitgeber was darauf
eingebildet dass wir ein Algorithmus
haben der erstmal ausfiltert wir suchen
sehr speziell schon fast diskriminierend
und alles was wir tun ist umzudrehen und
zu sagen okay zeig mir dein Talent und
ich suche dir die Aufgabe
[Musik]
das Jobcenter schickt jetzt regelmäßig
Arbeitslose auf kunstbaustellen etwa die
Hälfte der Kandidaten bleibt so wie
Alfons Krämer nach seiner
Krebserkrankung war er zunächst
arbeitslos nun arbeitet er hier seit
mehr als einem Jahr als ungelernte
Hilfskraft
[Musik]
das eigene Wohl für Selbstvertrauen für
Selbstbewusstsein es ist halt du fühlst
dich ganz einfach anders du bist nicht
von anderen Leuten ihren Geld abhängig
weil du verdienst dir dein Geld selber
wieder und du tust wieder was und du
bist halt wieder ein wertvolles Mitglied
der Gesellschaft
[Musik]
aber die Mühe verbucht cool als
Investition in die Zukunft also es sind
knappe 3 Millionen Arbeitslose aus
meiner Sicht das ist ein Potenzial von
mindestens eine Million
arbeitenden Personen es ist eine eine
riesengroße Menge an Personen die uns
helfen können in der Wertschöpfung
auf dieser Baustelle müssen
hunderttausende Meter Kabel verlegt
werden
Kunst Idee die Arbeit in Handgriffe
aufteilen nur für die wenigsten müsse
man gelernter Elektriker sein
Dampf dahinter mal dort wo wir
integrieren dürfen klappt es auch es ist
eigentlich nur eine Frage wie geht man
aufeinander zu wir begegnen man sich wie
kriegt man eine echte Chance und ja
andere Arbeitgeber können das auch
[Musik]
doch laut Umfragen ziehen nur 39 Prozent
aller Unternehmen
Langzeitarbeitslose überhaupt in
Betracht
und das obwohl das Jobcenter sogar für
bis zu zwei Jahre den kompletten Lohn
übernimmt
also ich habe mit sehr sehr vielen
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmern
gesprochen um für meine Idee zu werben
und das sind ganz mannigfaltige
Widerstände man kann den Eindruck
gewinnen dass die Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmer das große Problem noch
unterschätzen dass jetzt schon da ist
und das noch weiter auf uns zukommt
[Musik]
fahrlässig finde ich denn eines ist klar
tun wir nichts und lassen alles wie es
ist sind die Aussichten düster
[Musik]
bis 2016 verlieren wir ein Drittel der
erwerbstätigen weil die Bevölkerung
älter wird heute können etwa 47
Millionen Menschen arbeiten dann wären
es nur noch 31 Millionen
[Musik]
Landeskommando Thüringen Erfurt auch die
Bundeswehr kämpft mit den Auswirkungen
des demografischen Wandels den nächsten
vier Jahren verlassen rund 80.000
Soldaten die Truppe sowie heute
Oberstleutnant Michael Weckbach
[Musik]
ja von dem Soldatenleben bleibt
tatsächlich nur übrig die Unterwäsche
die Socken die Stiefel ansonsten wird
die ganze Uniform das ganze Grünzeug
wird alles abgegeben
[Musik]
roten Sand
ich kann ihn tatsächlich nicht sagen ich
freue mich oder ich bin traurig es ist
so ein mixing also kommt immer so in
Wellen also
Weckbach hat die Altersgrenze eines
Oberstleutnants erreicht mit 61
wie so viele ältere hätte auch er noch
ein paar Jahre dranhängen können
[Musik]
es ist soweit
das letzte Mal einmal Hose einmal fällt
Bluse
also auf die Frage ob ich zwei Jahre
länger mache ist natürlich nicht einfach
so in Fingerschnippen entschieden also
ich habe mir schon Gedanken gemacht ob
ich es nicht tue aber letztendlich wie
gesagt bin ich eben zu der Entscheidung
gekommen dass es für mich jetzt
tatsächlich auch gut ist und dass man
hier auch neues mal zulassen muss danke
das war's jetzt ne tschüss
noch eine Stunde bis die Laufbahn von
Michael wegbach mit einem letzten Appell
endet
mehr als 25000 Dienst Posten sind
derzeit bei der Bundeswehr nicht besetzt
das sind fast 16% der stellen
haben sie die Lücke zu schließen ist
schwer verbietet die Bundeswehr feste
Jobs aber für viele zielt eine andere
Sicherheit als die aus dem
Arbeitsvertrag die Bundeswehr ist eine
Armee da muss man sich klar sein und in
letzter Konsequenz geht es beim
Soldatenberuf ums töten und getötet zu
werden das heißt Sie können gar nicht
groß attraktiver werden weil das ist
immer irgendwo im Hinterkopf und mit
dieser Frage müssen Sie sich
auseinandersetzen bevor sie hier Soldat
oder Soldatin werden wenn sie das nicht
getan haben sind sicher falsch
[Musik]
einer geht doch wer kommt nach die
Bundeswehr betreibt 16 karrierecenter
ich darf in München einen ganzen Tag
lang dabei sein
früh morgens um 5:30 Uhr beginnt der
Bewerbertag
[Musik]
alles klar
was mir gleich am Morgen auffällt kein
Gebrüll kein Drill
es könnte sich einer Armee mit Nachwuchs
sorgen wohl auch nicht mehr leisten elf
Frauen und Männer wollen es heute
schaffen in die Bundeswehr zu kommen
krasser Tag also wenn man morgens um
5:30 Uhr startet und am Nachmittag weiß
ob sich das Leben verändert weil man
seinen Ziel erreicht hat und seinen den
Job bekommt für den man hier ist oder
die Ausbildung bekommt diese Anspannung
also wie groß der Tag ist und wie groß
auch die Herausforderung sind man wird
ja gesundheitlich intellektuell
sportlich in allen Bereichen geprüft das
ist schon krass Anspannung
wie überall buhlen sie auch bei der
Bundeswehr um Fachkräfte das heißt wird
hier eine Lücke geschlossen reist in der
Regel eine andere auf
Michael fakus will raus aus der
Pflegebranche und träumt von einer
Karriere als Gebirgsjäger
und mein Interesse am besten
zusammenpasst
du musst halt auch klettern können dann
muss er da auch also Bergsteigen
arbeitet im Rettungsdienst und will mit
43 Jahren noch mal was Neues beginnen
attraktiv ach das sind verschiedene
Bereiche dass man sich persönlich und
beruflich weiterentwickeln kann dass man
auch viele lebt und auch im Team
arbeitet die Kameradschaft wichtig ist
dass man eben nicht alleine ist die
Bundeswehr ist natürlich auch
wirtschaftlichen Bereichen guter
Arbeitgeber
[Musik]
das ausfallverfahren wurde angepasst
weil zu viele durchs Raster fielen vor
ihm liegt eine Brille die dürfen sie mal
über ihre Brille drüber setzen dann sind
wir schon durch
auch ich mache den Sporttest der ist
jetzt gleich dazu schaffen
[Musik]
denn der Personalbedarf ist riesig und
selbst die die hier durchkommen brechen
später
öfter wieder ab zuletzt hat jeder vierte
schon im ersten halben Jahr die
Ausbildung hingeschmissen
5000 Abbrecher
[Musik]
ich bestehe den Test mit befriedigend
wirklich das ist also mein Ziel war ja
nicht scheitern das ist mehr als ich mir
selber zugetraut hätte auch die
Ergebnisse der echten Bewerber stehen
fest
statt im Sanitätsdienst landet Julia
Grad als Bürokraft bei der Marine
für die allgemeine Grundausbildung und
anschließend dann eben noch
Wilhelmshaven oder dann auf der Fregatte
Frankfurt dann das ganze noch
spezifiziert wird für die entsprechende
Tätigkeit da vor Ort
auch Michael farkus hat es geschafft
jetzt auch bestanden der Diensteintritt
man wünschen sie denn zur Bundeswehr zu
gehen also entweder so früh wie möglich
das erste siebter
also mehr war heute gar nicht zu
erreichen oder ist das maximal zehn hier
ich freue mich sehr
jetzt noch nicht so aber
es ist schon ich bin sehr glücklich
darüber und wie
eine neue bundeswehr-karriere beginnt
und hier in Erfurt geht eine zu Ende
[Musik]
ich werde mich heute Abend fühlen wie
der Martini von James Bond geschüttelt
und und wahrscheinlich auch gerührt also
ich kann es nicht sagen ich muss es auf
mich zukommen lassen aber es ist
tatsächlich so wenn man jetzt so kurz
zur vom antreten steht also ja der
Herzschlag ist schon ein bisschen
schneller Blutdruck wahrscheinlich auch
ein bisschen höher normal wäre jetzt der
Abschluss Appell beendet nicht aber für
heute
meldest für die den deutschen Volker
geleisteten treuen Dienste spreche ihm
Dank und Anerkennung aus ein dreifaches
[Musik]
eigentlich will die Bundeswehr wachsen
von jetzt
183.000 auf 203.000 Beschäftigte doch
viele hier zweifeln daran ob das
überhaupt noch zu schaffen ist
[Musik]
eine weitere Lösungsidee gegen die
allgemeine Personalnot lautet daher
Zuwanderung denn selbst wenn wir im
Inland alle Hebel in Bewegung setzen
müssen trotzdem jedes Jahr 400.000
Menschen zu uns kommen und auch bleiben
[Musik]
ich bin im Uniklinikum Rostock schon
jetzt fehlen 200.000 Pflegekräfte in
deutschen Krankenhäusern und Heimen
die Vorstellung man hatten Unfall in
Herzinfarkt man braucht Hilfe und das
heißt keiner ist das um zu helfen es
gibt nicht genügend Pfleger es gibt
nicht genügend Ärzte wie sieht es hier
aus wie krass ist hier der Pflege
Notstand und vor allem was tun Sie um
Menschen zu finden die hier arbeiten die
versorgen die helfen
seit fünf Jahren versuchen sie in
Rostock Pflegekräfte aus sogenannten
Drittstaaten anzuwerben von außerhalb
der EU z.B aus Vietnam die ausgebildeten
Pflegerin müssen hier noch einmal eine
dreijährige Ausbildung machen
hier habe ich die Ausbildung gehabt und
dann finde ich dass die Ausbildung sehr
schön ist obwohl auch anstrengend ist
und aber die habe ich geschafft ja und
jetzt habe ich hier einen Traumjob mit
den tollen Kollegen und auch ganz gutes
Einkommen im Vergleich mit dem zu Hause
dann bin ich hier so zufrieden
die Uniklinik stellt Wohnung und hilft
bei Behördengängen genau dann geht es
wir betreiben natürlich diesen ganzen
Aufwand das ist ja ich will das mal als
Aufwand in Anführungszeichen sagen
natürlich weil das Ziel ist die die
internationalen Pflegefachpersonen auch
hier am Haus zu halten und in der Region
zu halten also wir wären ja blöd das
nicht zu tun weil sie brauchen
heute darf ich mir den deutschen
Klinikalltag anschauen und mithelfen ich
bin auf der kardiologischen wacheinheit
das ist eine Mischung aus normal und
Intensivstation
[Musik]
hier sind die Sachen dann
Größen denke ich mal müssen so passen
hier kommen Patienten die gerade
operiert wurden und intensiv
kontrolliert werden müssen
so moin moin wir schließen Sie jetzt an
die Überwachung an den Flur auf die
rechte Seite rumlaufen auf der linken
Seite kommt irgendwann Wäsche da sind
orangefarbene Kuscheldecken drin
ich erfahre viel zu oft sind die
Schichten hier unterbesetzt Hilfe kommt
aus Fernost
Linien sie ist eine von 120
Pflegekräften aus Vietnam die die Klinik
bis jetzt gewinnen konnte
ihr Gehalt gut 3300 € brutto plus
Zuschläge
[Musik]
wie schwer was für sie nach Deutschland
zu kommen also auch diese bürokratischen
hürdensprache lernen Anträge ausfüllen
Visum bekommen
nur die Deutsch schaffen das ist die
Hürde
und natürlich du weißt Deutschland hat
so viele Dokumente hast hier oben
viele Deutsche Pflegerinnen und Pfleger
wollen nur noch in Teilzeit arbeiten
oder ganz raus aus der Branche umso
wichtiger sind Mitarbeiterinnen wie Lynn
nyen doch so sehr sie gebraucht werden
es ist erstmal deutlich aufwendiger die
neuen Kolleginnen einzuarbeiten
so eine erste
Hürde ist das schon oder dass man dass
man sich fragt kann das gelingen ja
natürlich man hat am Anfang schon wenn
man als Behörden wir kriegen zwei
vietnamesische Auszubildende waren am
Anfang haben wir gedacht oh Gott wie
wird das sein also die verstehen ja
nichts und wie machen wir das wir haben
überhaupt keinen Plan gehabt man muss
natürlich auch sagen es gibt im
deutschen Patienten gut auch wirklich
Menschen die dann eben die
vietnamesischen Mitarbeiter so
diskriminiert diskriminiert bewerten und
auch ansprechen wo ich denke kann ich
wahr sein also
dass man sagt ja die vertie Tante habe
ich also selbst gehört und die
Philippinos und so ich sage nee das ist
eine Mitarbeiterin aus Vietnam keine
Philippine also es ist schon unglaublich
was man da so mal von manchen Patienten
hört sie sind das auch Gründe wieso so
Pflegerin Pfleger wiedergegangen sind
das könnte ich mir gut vorstellen weil
ich aber auch das muss man aushalten und
wenn das überhand nimmt ist das
natürlich auch eine Geschichte die man
nicht ertragen muss
fakt ist ohne Einwanderung würde unser
Gesundheitssystem kollabieren
jede siebte Pflegekraft kommt heute
schon aus dem Ausland insgesamt mehr als
250.000 das sind etwa doppelt so viele
wie noch vor fünf Jahren und auch jeder
siebte Arzt ist Ausländer
[Musik]
doch auch Zuwanderung wird den
Personalmangel nicht beheben können
bleibt eine weitere Lösung
Automatisierung
Maschinen nicht Menschen erledigen die
Arbeit
für Monika Schnitzer ist dass der
richtige Weg sie ist die Vorsitzende der
Wirtschaftsweisen berät die
Bundesregierung und ist die Expertin für
die aktuelle wirtschaftliche Lage
wir müssen damit rechnen dass die hohe
Inflation das Wachstum bis weit ins
kommende Jahr hinein noch dämpfen wird
längst gefährdet auch der Personalmangel
die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
Schnitzer setzt daher auf
Digitalisierung auf Roboter
das ist ja bisher oder lange von vielen
Menschen sehr kritisch gesehen worden
weil sie dachten dadurch gehen
Arbeitsplätze verloren und dann stehen
alle auf der Straße aber tatsächlich ist
es gerade umgekehrt das ist die Chance
um die Menschen die beschäftigt sind um
produktiver einsetzen zu können und sie
auch von vielen Arbeiten zu entlassen
die letztlich nicht besonders
befriedigend sind dass wir wirklich
leisten müssen ist diesen Wechsel zu
erleichtern indem wir Umschulungen
machen indem wir Weiterbildungen machen
Roboter und KI künstliche Intelligenz
übernehmen einfache Arbeit Menschen
bekommen eine Perspektive auf bessere
Jobs das ist das ideal
auf der Handwerksmesse in München kann
man sich diese Zukunft schon ansehen
hier werden Roboter gezeigt die nicht in
der großen Automobilindustrie helfen
sondern bei kleinen und mittleren
Unternehmen
wir wollen diesen Schleifer auf dieses
Longboard drauf sind
starten und jetzt bewegt sich der
Roboter
einmal richtig eingestellt kann der
Roboter im Akkord Skateboard Schleifen
oder auch Tische verschrauben Stuhlbeine
zurechtsägen Routinetätigkeiten
[Musik]
solche Roboter Kosten 30.000 bis 80.000
Euro und sollen nun in immer mehr
Branchen arbeiten
[Musik]
die Herausforderung gerade im ländlichen
Raum
müssen leider viele Läden gerade im
Bäckerhandwerk schließen weil sie keine
Bäcker mehr finden und unser
Grundgedanke hier so ein bisschen
skizziert war eigentlich zu sagen der
Bäcker kann eine Stunde später kommen
nachdem der Roboter bereits die die
Brötchen auf das auf das Blech gelegt
hat
aber die kaum noch jemand machen möchte
wenn also an allen Ecken Leute fehlen
könnten Roboter zu Helden der Arbeit
werden
wir müssen jetzt so früh wie möglich
Lösungen schaffen die dann verfügbar
sind wenn es wirklich eklatant wird denn
wir sind gerade erst am Beginn eines
Wandels eines kompletten Strukturwandels
der aus meiner persönlichen Sicht auch
nicht so schnell durch Zuzug oder durch
zusätzliche Qualifikation oder durch
eine attraktive Arbeitsplatz ergänzt
werden können
klar ist es gibt nicht den einen Ort wo
alle hin sind und es gibt auch nicht die
große Lösung mit der wir den
Arbeitskräftemangel in den Griff
bekommen
doch es gibt immer noch Millionen
Menschen die für ihre Arbeit brennen
die Herausforderung ist gigantisch
wir müssen endlich kluge Lösung finden
für zugewanderte
für Langzeitarbeitslose und für Mütter
und Jugendliche die es auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt schwer haben
[Musik]
es gibt viel zu tun
machen wir uns an die Arbeit
[Musik]